okay so House of the Dragon episode 5 is
now out and the entry sent us around a
big wedding between two of the major
houses as far as weddings go I've seen
worse when it comes to Game of Thrones
and all things considered it's probably
a big success cheers now as always
there's a ton of things to talk about
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking it all down going over the
book differences in it and also what are
theories for the future are we won't be
spoiling the major deaths at twists but
we might be discussing some things to
add context to what you see so if you
don't want anything potentially ruined
then I recommend that you turn off now
if you enjoy the breakdown then please
hit the thumbs up button and make sure
you subscribe as we cover the series
every week but out the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into house
of the Dragon
foreign
[Music]
what the book tells us is the air 115ac
you'll likely recognize the veil from
the main Game of Thrones series and it's
a big area where people like to go
skydiving here we see Lady Ria for the
first time and Damon has talked about
her at numerous points throughout the
season both in the show and book she's
referred to as the bronze [ __ ] and she
comes just as fast as she goes with us
getting her death in the opening now she
rides out hunting she comes across Damon
wearing his hood Incognito like he was
last week she mocks him for potentially
returning to consummate the marriage and
then says this line the veil sheep might
be willing even if I'm not this is
playing on the line with the High
Council in which Damon said the
following the veilman is said to [ __ ]
sheep instead of women I can assure you
the Sheep are prettier the book also
remarks on this line and Damon goes one
step further by saying that everyone in
the Bell [ __ ] them so you can see why
this guy isn't happy also I don't know
if that's a beard or wool around his
face but but moving on now Sheba
mentioned basically every time that the
veil is brought up with Damon even
saying that his sore dark sister was
meant for more than slaughtering them he
hated the veil feeling like he was
forced to take up this crap Kingdom
which is why he tries to move away from
his wife and onto other ones now here
hearing of the sheep thing shows that
Ria has informants and it lays the
groundwork for why people could be
suspicious over her death this has
massively changed things up from the
source material and though she died in
similar circumstances Damon had nothing
to do with it Rio was out hunting and
she ended up falling from her horse
which caused her to crack her skull off
a stone whether she was alive for nine
days after this where she lay bedridden
trying to recover she ended up getting
out of bed and whilst she walked around
for a bit she collapsed an hour later
and died immediately yeah she just gets
her head smashed like it's a like button
after that skydiving joke and this is
clearly carried out by Damon so that he
can gain power in the book after there
were rumors of him sleeping with
rhaenyra he was exiled from the kingdom
and thus he tried to get gain somewhere
else to live here though he's allowed
back to the wedding and it is important
to bear in mind that the big event we
see is the party before it and ushers in
a lot of the tournaments in the book
these lasted for days and end with
Kristen beating Joffrey in a tournament
rather than what we get here the episode
has the wedding take place immediately
after the initial banquet and it
condenses everything down including the
arrival of the greens Damon also made a
move on laner which we see playing out
here and to the best of my knowledge he
did take part in the tournaments now in
the Berks after he learned of her death
he flew from Bloodstone and attempted to
claim his inheritance yeah this happens
at the wedding celebrations whereas in
the work he's rejected by Lady Jane
Aaron rather than her cousin color the
king's ship on stormy seas and as seeing
Visa is sick here foreshadows what's to
come at the end of the entry this is
very much setting things in place for
the fall of the king and the boat ride
here juxtaposes the karma one from last
week they're riding out to Lord Corless
in order to try and get his son's hand
in marriage and the king is now living
on borrowed time unlike like the last
couple of entries where we had major
time jumps this all seems to be
happening not too long after the last
episode and we could Alison meeting her
father after his firing in the source
material Otto traveled to the kingdom
with his wife and Allison and the latter
tended to King jaharis she went to his
room when she was 15 and would read him
stories but they've sort of combined
events here with viserys as he later
ended up marrying her in the book
Otto still believes that raniera slept
with Damon but as we know from last week
that didn't happen however the buck is
filled with rumors which said they did
it over a number of nights and Damon
proposed that under the guise of
teaching her how to seduce a Christian
Cole in the source material he rejected
her advances however here he didn't and
it creates a lot of issues when she
decides to marry Into the valerians Now
the book also altered things on how she
lost her v card with it actually being
Lionel Strong's son that she apparently
lost her maidenhead too it keeps saying
maidenhead because that's how it is in
the book now he was brought up at
aegon's birthday to the king and he did
pop up last week shout out to you guys
guys are pointing out that Harwin was
the soldier that Rey ran into and this
is similar to how she lost that b card
in the book they then got it on and
though this didn't happen in the series
you can kind of see how the rumors
started to spread they don't do that but
yeah just important to bear in mind the
source material is made up of several
secondhand accounts talking about events
like this but as I haven't mentioned
that one yet I thought I'd drop it in
now Otto has worked out all the Angles
and he knows that when viserys dies that
the realm on accept it this will make
her kill aegon and the rest of Allison's
kids in order to secure her claim thus
Allison takes things into her own hands
and she wears green which we'll talk
about more in detail later on in the
video now order gets replaced by Lionel
strong who's been promoted from being
the master of laws the show plays fast
and loose with the timeline as Otto was
removed in 109 AC and in 111 AC the
rumors that Damon bang Ray started to
come out here though they happen side by
side and in the book Lionel said that
Damon should be executed for taking her
maidenhead what about this just exiled
him and we all kind of get everything
mushed together and after making it to
high tide Lord coolest doesn't come out
to greet the King which is seen as an
insult you can catch Elena and his body
clashing swords which I swear isn't a
euphemism this place is located in
Blackwater Bay and the book describes it
as displaying many of the treasures that
Lord call us found on his voyages this
includes crabbeater's mask which also
demonstrates the conflict that Damon
helped him out in didn't point it out in
our breakdown on the battle but this is
actually a fractured version of the mask
that the sons of the harpies wore in the
main Game of Thrones series could have
the weirwood tree which we see seemingly
bleeding this actually happened because
the trees had red sap and it used to
leak out of the cuts in the faces making
it appear like tears of blood these
faces were carved by the children of the
forests and later the first man would
end up worshiping them as being symbols
of the Gods of the forest in the garden
we see Lord lares who in the book is
nicknamed clubfoot due to his ankle
being Twisted during birth in the source
material real he's a very manipulative
character who's described as often
listening and spying on people of the
realm we actually saw this all the way
back in episode 3 when he sat down with
a group of women under the guise of
being unable to hunt woman is never
invited to speak one learns instead to
um
he sniffs away at a flower from braavos
that shouldn't really be thriving in
King's Landing which could be seen as a
way of planting the idea in Alison's
head that she has to rise up after all
that she's been through he snitches
about the plan T and this makes Alison
think that she did sleep with Daemon
however Kristen comes clean which I
swear isn't a euphemism and admits to it
now though it clears raniera Alison's
still pretty annoyed that Rey didn't
tell her about Sir Cole The Source
material talked about how Kristen was
deeply in love with her and that he
imagined a life with them together over
time it said that because he couldn't be
with her and she was off getting married
that he grew to be resentful this
explains his actions towards the end and
also why he gets pushed towards Alison
now back at the castle we see rhaenice
come in and greet her cousin which
causes the king to wince in pain after
she grabs his hand as we pointed out in
early breakdowns he had his fingers cut
off and it's possible that the infection
is spreading causing his other ones to
be in pain too now the disease that's
Terran King viserys apart is some
something that we've speculated over for
weeks now there's been lots of theories
such as it being diabetes rust in its
blood and a lot more in the books the
illness was never given a name but Paddy
considine has cleared things up in an
interview with Entertainment Weekly
though he initially thought it was
grayscale And The Tease of episode 5
even hinted towards it we now know the
truth and I am gonna take the L the
actor said he's actually suffering from
a form of leprosy his body is
deteriorating his bones are
deteriorating he's not actually old he's
still a young man in there he's just
unfortunately got this thing that's
taken over his body it becomes a
metaphor for being king and the stress
and strain that it puts on you and what
it does to you physically what it does
to you mentally I love this explanation
and it ties into the idea that those who
are unfit to lead will be kept by the
throne this was massively talked about
in the box and I did like it that they
were keeping it ambiguous though Paddy
has just spoiled it interestingly
leprosy can be transmitted quite easily
through long-term exposure with someone
meaning that Alison could end of getting
it too as mentioned earlier this isn't
talked about in The Source material but
the show could be changing it up to make
that be the case they then inform him
about lady rear and he ends up proposing
a marriage between the kids comes down
to surnames and the succession though
and though this won't let a Valerian be
king by name their child will take the
throne it's obviously completely
overrides aegon and viserys wants a
targaryens to Rule the Kingdom for the
next 700 years now another interesting
detail is that the other baby will be
born with the surname Valerian it will
change once they hit the throne cut at
the beach each let's go get away and we
see renira and Leno agreeing to some
compromises got a lot of flashes of
Danny here walking along the beach and
obviously the look of rhaenyra is based
on her but always hit the other way
either way lots of stuff coming out
including Leno's sexuality and though
his father thinks it's a phase it's
gonna cause a lot of problems once they
have a kid this will get a Target on its
back due to others viewing aegon as
being the rifle Heir the book discussed
is how Leno prefers the company of his
Knight and this is seen in his lover
Joffrey
that name Joffrey I hate it now Raines
has of course seen us first hand and
though she was Almost Queen sheharis
very much chose her cousin over his
daughter because it was the best way to
keep things at peace the bug goes into
how jiharis had one of the most peaceful
Reigns ever seen in the realm and this
is because he carried out choices like
this however at the opening of the
chapter that centers on the events this
show is inspired from very much sets the
tone for what's to come it says the
seeds of War are often planted during
times of peace and this was the case
with the family because the targaryens
were allowed to prosper due to the lack
of War they ended up having so many
children that there were really 14
claims for the throne many of them
wanted a Caesar for themselves which
ended up causing them all to turn on
each other had there been Wars in Death
then many of the kids would likely never
have been born so the piece very much
backfired in a lot of ways viserys was
adamant that he would keep the peace too
which is why he was so hesitant to join
the war against Krabby there he very
much looked at Jairus and wanted to
continue his legacy but this lack of
action enabled countless enemies to be
created viserys has left things wide
open and a lot of this episode is very
much about how the pair are doomed from
the off which is reflected in their
wedding cut across to a near a sailing
home and in case you missed our last
video and you might notice that the
Royal cabin also looks similar in design
to the one used on the Chariots for
their Horse Court Kristen is Rey's side
chick and they do change things up quite
a lot from the book so according to the
gossip mushroom Ray put herself over to
Kristen but he completely rejected her
however wanting to have his cake and eat
it he was still besided by the princess
shortly after this the wedding started
to get set up and from here we get
varying tales about what really happened
the book does say that Kristen ended up
slipping into her bedroom where he put
forward the idea that they should move
away together and that they'd be safe in
the free cities renero rejected this and
said that she wanted to be more than the
wife of a cell's sword which is
basically the Game of Thrones name for a
mercenary and we don't know for definite
if this tail is true enough but the
source material doesn't really talk
about them sleeping together as much as
rhaenyra seemed to be sick of Judy in
the crown in the first episode we see
how the burden of responsibility has
finally gotten to her and she stays in
her post still though if the king can
fling then she can too a Christian
doesn't want to be that though and he
says this so you want me to be your home
now the guy goes through a lot of
internal struggles this entry and he
ends up losing it clearly torn between
his duty station whether to subscribe to
the person he loves or not he goes on a
really interesting Arc and at the end of
the video I'll talk about where things
go with him in the book I will give a
spoiler warning so don't worry but he
strikes up in unlikely alliance with
Allison at this point he's called her
the queen and I was expecting it to be a
big misunderstanding with her thinking
he was confirming the Damon rumors
however he admits he had his dick in a
box like Rick and Varys and I think that
she very much sees him as someone she
can get on her side by showing Mercy the
more people she has on her side from is
the more powerful she'll be and though
she initially started off as a weak girl
her wedding dress shows her true
intentions can see Alison really sinking
her clothes into him early on and though
he could be sentenced to death I think
Kristen sees it almost as an act of
mercy and that he owes his life to her
curtiserus looking like me on Sunday
putting this video up at 3am and there's
a lot of symbolism and iconography in
this scene he sits in front of the model
of old valyria and the family of course
came from this and ended up ruling over
the Seven Kingdoms biliria was destroyed
in a volcanic eruption known as the Doom
of valyria and this is of course similar
to our own Pompeii it killed most there
including a lot of the dragons with the
Targaryen dragonlords being the only
major house that survived viz sits in
front of this Dune Monument towards the
city and we know that he is too due to
his illness taking over now he does seem
to regret that the songs about him won't
be about big Wars and that those who
remember him won't bring up battles
however he's told to find some comfort
in this as it's better to live in p but
Sarah's wishes that he'd been tested but
don't look a gift horse in the mouth
mate leave well enough alone now I
actually thought that he died at this
point as we get a lung Fade Out however
it just shows the arrival of Corliss and
also his Fleet got a lot of Dance of the
Dragons vibes from this imagery of two
sweeping down and in case you don't know
the term Dance of the Dragons carries a
lot with it the series sort of changes
things up from the book and it's
reordered certain events so we get a bit
of drama in the work we had the wedding
and then there was a giant tournament
held in honor of this it was at this
point that Damon returned with his new
kingdom and he handed this over it's
also at the tournament where the green
and black rivalry is formed as well as
the events with sir Kristen so the book
explains it as all those in support of
Alison and aegon show this by wearing
green on the other side of this those
are back raniera where the typical
Targaryen red and black hence the name
greens and blacks now the tournament saw
Kristen attacking Harwin strong who as
we mentioned earlier was the one who
took rhaenyra's maidenhead
maidenhead not approved though I will
say they had sex now he ended up hitting
harwin's body so badly that he broke his
collarbone and elbow the both of which
were completely shattered anyway this
was under tournament rule so it was fine
however what caused the controversy that
led him to Alison was the attack on gr3
similar to what we see here named
Joffrey
Geoff Elon mouth he was nicknamed the
night of kisses and he was secretly
Leno's lover in the tournament Kristen
beat the crap out of him and he hit him
so badly with morning star that he
completely cracked his head open Joffrey
then died six days later without
regaining Consciousness and Kristen was
spurned across the kingdom by all except
Alison the tournament here is condensed
into just being a fight after Kristen
becomes a Wedding Crasher and loses it
over what's going on be like Joffrey
tries to turn him whilst also being like
we all have to keep each other's secret
and due to Kristen taking a bow he
doesn't want the stuff with rhaenyra
getting out this is another Factor as to
why he loses it and does the things that
he does now the Lannister twins arrive
both played by Jefferson Hall and at
this point Thailand is the master of
ships in the book both he and his
brother tried to marry rhaenyra but here
it's just been Jason now after the
valerians show up Damon returns much to
the Chagrin of his brother as we
mentioned in the book he was exiled
after the rumors of rhaenyra but he came
back to the tournament wearing black and
red in the book it's said that the
Rivalry between the two factions could
be seen on full display at this event
once the dragons of the two sides
started snapping at each other here
though it's ushered in by Alison's
arrival and Why this color is so
offensive is because the beacon on
Hightower is turned to Green to Signal
wall Hightower is of course Alison and
Otto's surname and this is a declaration
in front of everyone that things are
gonna kick off symbolically it also
happens during the speech about uniting
the houses metaphorically showing how
the greens will disrupt the entire Union
Alison also goes to her uncle who also
just so happens to be wearing green and
they say that they stand with her Damon
is accused of his this point I don't
know if he's the kind of person you want
to go against mate guy basically did
this to crab feeder
from me now Damon ends up trying down
with Elena and it's clear that he's
after another kingdom he of course
Allied himself with the valerians and
the war against crab feeder so it makes
sense had he tried this strategy next he
also seems to be flirting with renera
and she even tempts him with taking her
to Dragonstone renera was named the
princess of this in the books though
they also discussed how Damon wanted the
kingdom to himself before we can see
what happens though the fight breaks out
with Kristen hitting Leno and smashing
Joffrey's facing viserys also starts to
bleed from his nose and he finally
collapses at the wedding next to the
weirwood tree Kristen goes to commit
sebaku which is a term that first
originated in Japan at the Samurais
disembowel themselves it has many uses
and was predominantly put in place when
samurais were Behind Enemy Lines and
they took their own life instead of
being captured however it was also seen
to be used by those that broke the code
of honor which is very much the case
with sir Kristen Knights weren't meant
to go around sleeping with the
princesses and they all took vows to
ensure this wasn't the case in the books
one of the reasons that rhaenyra was
hesitant to go off with him is because
he broke his vows and she thinks that
he'd do the same when it came to the
ones for marriage Alison then calls out
to him and stops him from doing this
after this drops down we cut to a puddle
of blood as well as a rat scurrying to
lick it up now the order of this is of
course a bit off as Alison is at
baserus's side when he falls to the
ground I think that with him being like
this that he probably wouldn't have left
his side either and likely would have
spent the night nursing him now she will
likely went to Kristen stopped him and
then proceeded with the wedding which is
when viz collapsed I do want to talk
about what's coming down the line with a
pair but in case you don't want any
spoilers I thought I'd give my review
first now I thought this was a slightly
slower entry than the first three but
also had so much going on with it like
the rat coming for the blood at the end
we've watched as the rats in the cast
have slowly start to circle the king so
that they can pray off his bloodline
which I swears on a reach his ending
shot is very symbolic and just in the
same way that pesaris fell we have this
house of cards starting to come crashing
down raniera is obviously doing the
whole wedding for show as is her husband
and it's not the best Union that the
pair can stand on the declaration of war
by Alison is fascinating to watch I feel
like this show is at its strongest when
you've seen the subtext to what's going
on rather than what's being said this is
basically just one big chess game
playing out in real time and even
knowing the book it's nice seeing how
unpredictable some of it really is I
really think there's a slow burn to
these entries but they always go out of
the bang that makes it worth sticking
through the slightly longer paced pot
overall really enjoying the show and I
hope that you're having fun with the
breakdowns alright so feature spoilers I
just want to talk about the stuff with
Alison and Kristen but if you don't want
any of that Rune then thanks for sitting
until this part of the video I'll see
you on the next one you still here okay
so after the tournament Alison ended up
taking Kristen as her personal sword and
renera lost her bodyguard she does
slowly turning against Rey Kristen ended
up becoming a strong supporter of Alison
and and he was very much a person that
pushed the idea that her child was the
true Heir he also helped to train her
kids as Swordsmen and became one of
Alison's greatest allies this pushed the
greens in Black Wall further than it had
been with them vying for the throne
anyway that's all the spoilers that's
the video hope you had a good tease of
what's coming next time and I'd love to
hear your thoughts on it below just to
let you know we're running a competition
right now and giving away three copies
of dollar and thunder on the 15th of
October all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
it and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode we picked the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now similar to you
and message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers if you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out one
of our breakdowns on screen right now
and huge thank you for all the support I
hope you've enjoyed working with us up
until this halfway point in the series
and let's roll on the next five episodes
without the way thanks for saying
through the video I've been poor I'll
see you next time take care
foreign
[Music]